Welcome to the show.
It's a new week.
It's a new day, and it is not a new world
in terms of what's going on with Corona virus.
It's much the same as what was going on last
week.
Worse in some places.
And yet Donald Trump had a rally.
He did it.
Sixty two hundred people showed up in Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
Not the 62000 that Donald Trump predicted.
They didn't really have one million people
trying to go is Donald Trump's campaign manager
claimed.
But we will get to all of that and we're going
to spend some time today talking about the
different aspects of this rally, because there
are so many stories and types of stories and
because they're so emblematic of much of what
is wrong with the United States of America
right now.
So we're going to go through step by step
how Donald Trump's rally was overhyped.
They claim a million people wanted to go.
They got sixty.
Two hundred.
It was irresponsible.
Oklahoma is a Corona virus hotspot six Trump
staffers sent in advance to setup for the
rally tested positive, chock full of ignorant
people was the rally.
People who vote and we're going to talk about
the issue of anti intellectual ism in the
United States and the content of the rally
itself.
Riddled with horrifying admissions from Donald
Trump.
Each of which would be a scandal in a normal
administration.
So I'm going to get to crowd size and that
part, I'm going to get to the public health
component.
I'm going to get to interviews with some of
the attendees.
Were going to get to all of it.
But we have to start with what the president
said during the rally and what Trump said
during the rally was the less driv of just
how triggered Donald Trump truly is because
of the things that people say on the Internet
about him.
Donald Trump during this rally spent more
than 20 minutes just on his water drinking
and ramp walking problems.
And Trump's actual speech also shed light
on the reality that Trump has no real 2020
campaign message.
And this is something I also am going to talk
about a little bit later.
Things aren't good.
So Trump can't really campaign on things being
good unless he lies, which he has no problem
doing.
And to some degree he has been.
But the attacks on Biden are mostly ad hominem.
So you've got no real message.
Attacks on your opponent are ad homonyms.
We have 20 percent real unemployment and there
is no actual case being made for his reelection.
And that was very much represented during
this rally.
It was one of the most jingoistic and self-centered,
xenophobic, ignorant horror shows that I've
seen in politics for a long time.
And let's get into just a couple of the specifics
of what Donald Trump said.
Now, this is this is a borderline criminal
admission that Donald Trump made.
It's a murderous admission.
Donald Trump admitted during the rally that
he asked for testing to be reduced, to be
slowed down because he knew if we tested more,
we would find more cases.
This is borderline criminal.
This leads to deaths.
It is murderous.
Take a look at what Donald Trump admitted
to test of what you do, testing to that extent.
You're gonna find more people.
You're gonna find more cases.
So I said to my people, slow the testing down,
please.
They test, they test, we had tests that people
don't know what's going on.
We got tests.
We got another one over here.
I really need people to understand.
Testing saves lives.
This is tantamount to murdering people deliberately.
It's not all we've been struggling and we
just haven't yet gotten testing where we want
it.
This is Trump saying the disaster of testing
was partially.
He was asking for testing to be held back.
And the White House later realizing the degree
of of insanity that this is.
The White House later said it was a joke.
There was no indication that it was a joke.
This is not something to even joke about,
obviously.
And I please understand that testing finds
more cases like in the short term.
OK.
If we don't do any tests today, we don't find
any cases today.
But testing identifies people who shouldn't
be going out.
It slows the spread.
And in the long run, more testing reduces
cases.
The more testing you do over the long run,
the number of people who are testing positive
should decline.
And it is murderous to suggest do less testing.
Now, Trump then again pulled out this pejorative
name for Corona virus Cung flew during the
rally.
You could tell he was sort of manic from the
crowd's energy, despite it being a far smaller
crowd than he was anticipating.
Clearly still hopped up from the crowd and
throwing Cung flu out there.
It's a disease, without question, has more
names than any disease in history.
I can name comes Lou.
I can name.
19 different versions of them.
So the crowd cheering in particular, you see
one woman behind Trump who sort of raised
her fist in a sign of victory, I guess, at
Trump calling the virus king flu, certainly
a Pyrrhic victory, if nothing else.
Then Trump drank from a glass of water and
the crowd went wild.
Now, that sounds weird.
It is weird.
Think about how low the bar is that Trump
drinking out of a glass of water with one
hand, I guess, to prove his critics that he's
able to do it.
He got a standing ovation.
That is how low the expectations are.
Take a look.
Trump drinking water, throwing the glass aside,
and the crowd goes absolutely wild.
And I don't want to get water on the tie and
I don't want to drink much.
So I lifted up the water.
I should.
We have a little glass of water.
Where the hell did this water come from?
Where did it come from?
And I looked down on my tie because I've done
it.
I've taken water and it's still down and you
type.
Does it look good for a long time?
And frankly, the tie is never the same.
So I put it up to my lip.
I don't I say because I don't want it just
a case.
And they gave me the disease.
They gave me another disease.
This is a very, very sick guy.
I said Trump doesn't have a 20/20 message.
Maybe the message is I can drink water with
one hand and they think that that that will
be better than what Joe Biden is offering.
Maybe they're right.
We'll know in four and a half months.
But what a time to be alive.
Twenty minutes spent rambling about how he
can walk down a tramp ramp and drink water
with with a single hand.
So it was genuinely disgusting.
And also, as I said, representative of so
many of Trump's problems.
No message, no vision.
A disjointed speech in a red state that he
easily won and still unable to fill.
Barely a third of the 19000 steep seats in
the arena.
And we are supposed to believe that there
is any reasonable case to reelect this guy.
Well, that's what I'm going to tackle next,
because we're going to look at interviews
with Trump supporters at the rally.
And what you will hopefully quickly realize
is that when these are your supporters, maybe
you don't need the facts on your side to justify
reelection when these are your supporters.
Maybe it doesn't matter that you have no case
for your own reelection.
Let's talk about
that next.